well the fun group welcome to detention
Spencer that Finnish fridge Martha
you're all here for a reason you should
be thinking about who you are and who
you want to be
you'll have plenty of time to figure
that out while you're cleaning out the
basement are you gonna help are you -
pretty I'm too pretty
yeah what's this a game for those who
seek to find a way to leave their world
behind Jumanji you pick a character and
you're that person in the game which
ones real quick I don't think it matters
how much you spin ball sounds like a
badass I'll be the curvy genius dr.
smolder brave style I guess I'm Ruby
roundhouse
guys hey where's the rest of me my god
Brits can't bridge who use me Spencer
[Music]
why are wearing half a shirt and short
shorts in the jungle think we got sucked
into Jumanji and we become the avatars
we chose so that means Bethany Bethany
don't look at it I'm an overweight
middle-aged man I don't have my claritin
and all I see around here is Paul well I
don't have a top two feet of my body
damn there's a man right there don't cry
don't cry don't cry it's gonna be okay
this is a video game which means we all
have special skills
I was so intense I like can't even with
this place
[Music]
maybe we'll what metal game machine
muscle like you
get in there saver I'm not coming jitter
now you get it man
yeah I got a backpack you don't get
water with a backpack everybody knows
down
[Music]